bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sénat pour la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
neuf questions cet après-midi pose est
donc au gouvernement avec deux questions
autour de la décentralisation c'est
évidemment le thème qui intéresse le
plus les sénateurs en ce moment les
projets du gouvernement en matière de
décentralisation une question aussi du
sénateur ump christian cambon autour du
budget de la défense il ya beaucoup
d'interrogations qui se posent autour de
ce budget et notamment la commission des
affaires étrangères est vrai avoir plus
d'éclaircissement de la part du ministre
de la défense jean yves le drian ce
n'est pas lui qui va répondre aux
sénateurs cambon mais michel sapin le
ministre des finances et puis le sénat
s'intéresse aussi beaucoup à la réforme
des rythmes scolaires on va en parler
tout de suite avec nos deux premiers
invités il y a une mission d'information
qui a travaillé sur cette question des
rythmes scolaires pendant six mois au
sénat le rapport a été rejetée hier par
les membres de cette mission on va voir
pourquoi avec nos deux invités il y à
deux questions qui sont posées au
ministre de l'éducation cet après midi
sur autour des rythmes scolaires une
question de l'ump est une question du
parti
socialiste donc nos deux premiers
invités c'est françoise cartron bonjour
mais avec nos sénatrice socialiste de la
gironde vous étiez la rapporteur de
cette mission d'information sur les
rythmes scolaires et puis jean claude
carle qui connaît bien ces questions
d'éducation vous vous êtes sénateur ump
de la haute-savoie d'abord françoise
cartron le rejet du rapport hier lors de
la dernière réunion de votre mission
d'information à ce que ça veut dire que
mathieu dumont votre avoir rejeté il
part à la poubelle il ne sert plus à
rien et bien voilà c'est donc ce que je
déplore c'est d'ailleurs une première
vous le savez dans les annales et dans
l'histoire du sénat il n'y a eu jamais
de rapports rejeté il ya déjà eu de
rapport à new york pour des commission
denquête d'émissions d'informer le nom
de rapport rejeté il n'y en a pas eu
jamais il y a eu des rapports pour
lesquelles parfois il y avait dix ans y
ont entre la présidente de la mission et
la reporter ou le rapporteur mais ce qui
était proposé hier au vote c'est à dire
on pouvait donner acte parce que voter
la mission s'est donné acte aussi du
travail qui est mené et faire une
contribution complémentaire à ce rapport
sans le rejeter parce que leur jeter
c'est vrai ça veut dire mettre six mois
de travail à la poubelle et je pense que
ce n'est pas une bonne mesure et un bon
respect du travail des uns et des autres
alors on va voir pourquoi ce rapport a
été rejetée jean claude carle vous vous
étiez à l'origine de cette mission
d'information c'est votre groupe le
groupe ump qui a demandé à ce qu'il y
ait une mission d'information sur cette
question des rythmes scolaires ici au
sénat on le sit in règle la haute
assemblée c'est bien de le rappeler pour
nos téléspectateurs
quand une mission d'information et bien
la direction de cette mission et
paritaire c'est à dire qu il y à la fois
un président aux rapporteurs de droite
et de gauche donc c'était la règle pour
cette mission d'information alors une
fois que vous lui l'aviez demandé une
fois que la rapporteure et puis sa
présidente qui était la sénatrice ump
catherine tremblay ont travaillé
ensemble main dans la main pendant six
mois pourquoi refuser toutes les
conclusions de ce rapport vous n'auriez
pas pu vous mettre d'accord d'abord si
elle a été refusée c'est qu'il ya pas eu
de majorité et si ya pas eu de majorité
c'est que notamment dans vos sein de la
majorité sénatoriale
il n'y a pas eu l'ensemble des voies qui
ont voté et que je rappelle que les
sénatrices et sénateurs communistes
n'ont pas pris part au vote donc avant
de rejeter la responsabilité sur l'ump
c'est d'abord un échec de la majorité
puisqu'elle n'a pas réussi à avoir une
majorité au niveau du
bien sûr que si bien sûr que si ça y
sont majoritaires donc avant de reporter
la responsabilité sur l'ump que la
majorité sénatoriale balaye devant sa
porte alors nous ne l'avons pas d'opter
pour deux raisons parce que ce
7 les propositions qui était faite par
madame le reporter et je les dis si
certaines vont dans le bon sens elle
était insuffisante et imprécises
insuffisante et imprécises sur deux
points qui sont deux inquiétudes de la
part des acteurs de la communauté
éducative et en particulier des élus
500d des inquiétudes au niveau
organisationnel et au niveau financier
au niveau organisationnel
car le décret de monsieur peillon laisse
à peine quatre semaines pour mettre les
choses intensément vous de monsieur
hamon pardonnez-moi le t3 le messie
et deuxièmement si au niveau financier
au niveau financier qu'est la grande
inquiétude de des élus et si madame
quartier propre garantie pour la il ya
des grimm et la libre qui qui qui
pérennise quelque peu mais qui ne
sécurise pas et le niveau financier
notamment alors on va laisser la
croissance cartron mais juste une petite
question d'un point de vue politique
jean claude caron n'avait pourtant
l'impression quand le nouveau ministre
l'éducation à publier son décret que ben
il vous le trouviez un petit peu plus à
votre goût quand même que le décret
peillon vous l'avez dit notamment lors
d'un déplacement de la mission
d'information dans votre département sa
voix vous l'avais dit à la presse
quotidienne régionale ça semble le plus
à votre goût pourquoi avoir changé
d'avis cette semaine est ce que c'est
parce qu'il faut à tout prix
clivé politiquement et se distinguer des
positions du parti socialiste tout pas
du tout quand le décret de monsieur
hamon est tombé jeudi s'il va dans le
bon sens mais il est insuffisant je dis
la même chose pour les propositions de
madame cartron alors cartron alors moi
je voudrais faire un bref rappel les 18
propositions ont été co rédigé avec la
présidente de la mission ne parle pas
pour l équipe car nous avons une réunion
de travail le mardi soir et à la demande
de madame tremblay nous avons re écrit
un certain nombre de préconisations et
madame renée n'a demandé aucun rajout
donc il y avait pour moi un consensus
d'où mon étonnement ensuite alors après
monsieur monsieur carle dont nous dit
abel monsieur le décret de monsieur
hamon c'est bien mais pas assez et c'est
toujours comme ça c'est à dire chaque
fois qu'on avance c'est bien mais pas
assez sauf que
dire que les maires ne seront pas prêts
dans votre département monsieur carlos
savoie où vous m'avez demandé de venir
au lundi sans le dasein à 10 100 % des
communes ont déposé un projet donc c'est
pas parce qu'ils sont légalement de
madame évident qu'ils savent faire je
pense à faire cependant ne nous
racontons pas tout ça c'est que vous
leur a causé le problème il est là ah
ben voilà donc c'est à nous à blaye
faisait alors qu'on le voit bien ça nous
a interdit tout ce qui nous est imposée
nous fait peur ça a été dit par un
enseignant s'étaient dits par un élu et
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui un problème
tels que ceux des rythmes scolaires ne
peut pas être décrétée et moi je
souhaite que ce soit le parlement qui
décide il faut peut-être alors il faut
peut être rappeler que le décrit
effectivement de parement demande pose
une date limite au maire pour y
organiser c'est à dire d'ici le 6 juin
prochain dans ce délai trop rapide non
pardon ce délai du 6 juin d'abord tous
les maires qui était en place et qui ont
été réélus ont eu deux ans pour préparer
c'est d'ailleurs le cas de megève où
nous étions megève nous a montré un
projet finalisé et bien élaborés dont
reste la pratique séculaire est
nécessaire la problématique concerne les
nouveaux maires sans doute et c'est là
que dans les préconisations du rapport
nous disons bien au ministre il est
urgent d' accompagner ces nouveaux
maires mais les nouveaux maires ils
n'arrivent pas non plus sur une terre
aride où rien n'avait été fait sauf
d'aider des élus qui auraient voulu
prenez le pire mais il n'ya pas d'élus
qui travaille comme cela parce que les
élus sont responsables et ils savaient
que cette nuit cette réforme devait se
mettre en place donc ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point dire que ça n'a
jamais été débattue au parlement c'est
faux j'ai là justement les comptes
rendus des débats lors de la loi de
refondation de l'école contexte le parti
que l'on teste l'opposition ce que nos
maisons et le texte qu'une envie me
contenir débat sur le décret le long
article 47 je vais pas vous lire toutes
les pages intervention de madame morin
desailly carretta de quelle loi de la
loi de fondation de l'école voilà vous
l'avez là donc on ne peut pas dire qu'on
en a jamais parlé je peux y lit à même
allé au trio là n'avaient jamais parlé
toile car là donc c'est faux moi je
souhaite on voit bien les difficultés de
mise en place ça fait deux ans qu'on en
parle et bien je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
est temps que le parlement s'en
saisissent et nous allons déposer une
proposition de loi qui aura deux
objectifs demandé un moratoire jusqu'à
la rentrée 2015 et une compensation
financière sur le coût réel et non pas
sur le coût estimé aujourd'hui qui est
dans le meilleur des cas de 90 et
gagnent inquiète de l'ordre de 50 2,50
euros aujourd'hui toutes les estimations
et je demande à tous mes maire demande
va me demande voyez une estimation du
coup ça oscille entre 150 et 300 euros
alors vous est ce que vous avez fait une
estimation du coût par élève france
parce que ça c'était dans votre rapport
bien sûr bien sûr qu'elle chiffre à
l'heure nous nous arrivons dans une
fourchette entre 100 et 300 euros et
pourquoi cette fourchette assez énorme
et je vais régler les normes entre
sourds et 3 c'est bien sûr qu'on parle
d'un coût moyen par élève il s'offre sa
dépense ce duo très loin et on est loin
des chiffres du ministre non mais
attendez ça dépend ce que l'on prend en
compte c'est à dire que dans les
communes où on décide que pour les
activités périscolaires il faut racheter
tout le matériel il faut racheter tous
les placards il faut racheter toutes les
armoires parce qu'on ne peut pas
mélanger le matériel hors temps scolaire
le matériel scolaire bien sûr que c'est
un coup tech orbitant dans les communes
où il n'ya pas de cantine parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya encore des
comptines des communes où il n'a pas de
restauration scolaire organisé bien sûr
que ça coûte cher mais ça on imagine
vous êtes d'accord pour dire finalement
1 françoise cartron que ce problème
financier c'est ça reste le problème
principal pour l'instant de la mise en
oeuvre de cette réforme des rythmes
scolaires et c'est là-dessus peut-être
que le gouvernement doit travailler ben
moi je vais vous dire la réponse qui a
été fait à megève par l'adjointe de
megève à la question de monsieur carle
qui lui a dit mais ça a un coût de cette
réforme qu'est ce que vous en pensez et
jeu et c'est pas elle n'est pas
soupçonné d'être téléguidés par le parti
socialiste
adjointe de megève a dit pour nous ce
n'est pas un problème le coûte parce que
la seule question c'est un problème de
choix et nous savons peut-être deux
mines de megève a peut-être un tout
petit peu plus de moyens la grande
différence c'est qu'un projet de megève
il a été concertée entre tous les
acteurs entre les élus les enseignants
les parents depuis deux ans et profite
de gens c'est ça les met en place est
ici c'est un problème de méthode et là
vous voulez la pause et en trois
semaines alliant sérieux l'imposer à
trois semaines ça ne concerne que les
maires nouvellement élu alors s'arrêtant
à 40 % des mères un peu pointe non non
arrêtant de l'ariège comment cela se
fait-il que dans votre département 100 %
des projets soient soit au poids voilà
ce qu'ils sont légalistes ils demandent
lauga s'il devait appliquer la loi et je
leur ai dit le jeu fait la loi il faut
l'en qui sont prêts dans le jeu sont
prêts france face aux cartes seront
quand même sur cette réforme où on voit
le bien très sensible 1,2 depuis le
début sur cette réforme des rythmes
scolaires est-ce que c'était finalement
très opérant pour la peintre est est
très opportun pour le gouvernement de
faire deux décrets successifs plutôt
qu'une loi effectivement qui ont été
débattus de façon un petit peu plus
ouverte et à l'assemblée est ici au
sénat mais la loi n'aurait rien la voix
lui parce que monsieur non sûrs dont
deux je peux qu'approuver débat
démocratique je mets le débat il est là
je vous donne les 40 pages de début
c'est pas sur le débat monsieur carle a
déposé une loi qui a été discuté le 21
janvier 2014 vous avez refusé à donner
ben oui donc il ya eu le débat non il
faut pas confondre monsieur carle c'est
pas parce que vous déposez une loi
qu'elle doit être votée automatiquement
je mets dans le cross media bar
respectant démocratie dans s'exprimer
donc ne mélangeons pas les choses le
débat il a eu lieu il ya eu la loi de
monsieur carle il ya eu le débat de
formation l'école les votes non
conformes aux espérances de monsieur
carle mais bien sûr pour l'instant pour
l'instant il n'y avait pas une majorité
au sénat pour abord abondé vos
propositions mais côté là au nom acte
prendrait acte et je pense que s'il n'y
a pas une majorité c'est parce que vos
propositions justement ne correspondait
pas à ce qu'attend la mauricie pour moi
non mais sur vos votes loi en gie a été
quelques jours au togo moi je pars de
alors françoise cartron je voulais juste
évoqué un aspect du décret de benoît
hamon un effet un petit peu détournée on
voit qu'il ya certaines communes qui
commencent à mettre en place toutes les
activités autour des rythmes scolaires
seulement le vendredi après midi c'est
le cas de lyon c'est le cas par exemple
en banlieue parisienne de la ville de
clamart est-ce que ça c'est pas un effet
détourné et peut-être pervers du nouveau
décret de benoît hamon c'est de
repousser toutes ces activités
extrascolaires si on veut dire le
vendredi après-midi et pas les autres
jours tout à fait tout à fait mais comme
dans toute loi et dans toute mesure vous
avez parfois des esprits je dirais
peut-être mal intentionnés qui détourne
le bien fondé de telle ou telle loi de
telle ou telle directive dont - et dans
le rapport nous avons bien mis c'est une
proposition simple faire que lorsque on
met les activités le vendredi après midi
il y est classe le samedi matin dans le
décret de monsieur hamon il y a aussi la
nécessité monsieur hamon l'a réaffirmé
que les recteurs donne l'autorisation à
l'organisation de la semaine scolaire
telle qu'elle sera proposée donc je
pense qu'il y a nécessairement un
contrôle de l'état par rapport au bien
fondé de cette proposition vous demandé
au rectorat d'être vraiment gilles en
qualifications de l'organisation de voir
de voir si cela correspond à un vrai
projet éducatif territorial et si
l'intérêt de l'enfant est préservé c'est
que cela qui doit nous guider dans le
car là je suis désolé mais le rectorat
ne pourra que constater et j'irais pas
jusqu'a dire que monsieur collomb est un
esprit détourner un set c'est un effet
pervers 2 du décret de monsieur hamon
qui a des effets sur l a7 en effet de
serre que nous ayons le concerne en fait
si on le constatera que la grande
majorité des journées complètes seront
le vendredi vous verrez mais c'est une
mauvaise lecture moi j'en prends un
exemple le même décret il a été alors
pardon je vais citer alain juppé il est
surtout pas socialiste mais à bordeaux
alain juppé avec ce même décret en a
fait une lecture différente mais qui à
mon avis une solution intelligente c'est
à dire répartir en quatre grands
secteurs géographiques la ville et
tournées sur les quatre jours de la
semaine pour la demie après midi libéré
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
venu sur ce débat autour des rythmes
scolaires donc rapport rejeté hier au
sénat françoise cartron vous
interpellerait dans quelques instants
lors de cette séance aux questions
d'actualité bien le ministre de
l'éducation benoît hamon catherine
tremblay qui présidait également cette
mission d'information posera également
une question au même ministre de
l'éducation je vous remercie tous les
deux je vous laisse rejoindre la séance
puisqu'il entendu la sonnerie de séance
retentir on va attendre maintenant que
le gouvernement et le président
du sénat jean pierre bel s'installe pour
démarrer cette séance des questions
d'actualité je vous rappelle également
qu'il y aura une question sur le budget
de la séance et reprise attendue du
ministre des finances michel sapin voilà
jean pierre bel
débute cette séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement l'écoutant
je rappelle que l'auteur de la question
ainsi que le ministre pour un réponse
disposent chacun de deux minutes trente
la parole est à madame laurence cohen
pour le groupe crc monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues après dix ans de
démantèlement des services de l'état
aggravée par la stagnation de leur
salaire et une saignée des effectifs les
fonctionnaires manifestent en ce moment
dans l'unité syndicale
alors qu'ils espéraient un changement
d'orientation politique avec la nouvelle
majorité présidentielle force est de
constater qu'ils sont toujours les
cibles de la rigueur budgétaire
comme le souligne le président de
l'observatoire des inégalités qu'il soit
territoriaux hospitaliers ou de l'état
c'est la promesse d'une cinquième année
sans augmentation de salaire un record
historique ce gel de la valeur du point
d'indicé jusqu'en 2017 qui touche 5
millions de personnes participent d'une
logique inacceptable d'austérité
salariale à l'égard d'agents exerçant
des missions de service public
privilégié les fonctionnaires le
traitement de plus d'un million d'entre
eux tournent autour du smic auxquels il
faut ajouter des dizaines de milliers
d'employés à temps partiel une majorité
de femmes qui ne perçoivent qu'une
fraction de ce même smic la faible
revalorisation des plus bas salaires
prévus le 1er janvier n'y changera pas
grand chose à cette mise à la diète aux
conséquences dramatiques pour le pouvoir
d'achat donc pour la consommation et la
relance de l'économie il faut agir a
ajouté une attaque violente contre
l'emploi les services publics de
proximité l'émission l'état
d'autant que la décision de refonte
territoriale risque de créer elle seule
un véritable séisme en termes d'emploi
la casse des services publics de
proximité c'est moins de services rendus
à la population
une mise en péril de la cohésion sociale
une aggravation des inégalités sociales
et territoriales
croyez vous vraiment qu'il y ait trop de
fonctionnaires quand les communes se bat
pour conserver une école un bureau de
poste un centre de sécurité sociale un
tribunal où un hôpital de proximité
croyez vous vraiment que les personnels
hospitaliers soit tension nombre alors
que les ars pour suivre les
regroupements de services que les
maternités centres d'interruption
volontaire de grossesse sont au coeur de
la tourmente madame la ministre nous
sommes de plus en plus nombreux à ne pas
comprendre que vous poursuiviez une
politique condamné dans les urnes et qui
aggrave la crise serez vous entendre les
personnels le 19 mai prochain lors de
l'ouverture des négociations et répondre
aux besoins urgents des agents en
commençant par mettre un terme au gel de
leurs salaires et à la baisse des
effectifs dans les services publics je
vous remercie merci la parole et à
marylise lebranchu ministre la
décentralisation réforme de l'état
fonction publique merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice
augmenter le poids la liste à débat au
coeur effectivement de mes rencontres et
les organisations syndicales depuis
maintenant une deux ans je rappelle
quand même pour que les choses soient
bien claires entre nous tous ceux que
j'ai rappelé aux organisations
syndicales c'est lorsqu'on augmente le
point lundi c'est à dire un élément de
référence du salaire de la fonction
publique on en demande des salaires de
façon proportionnelle ce qui veut dire
que les uns et en particulier les plus
bas salaires les à peu près un million
huit cent mille plus bas salaires de la
fonction publique ont quelques euros
quand ceux qui ont la chance d'être a
plus plus plus comme on dit dans notre
langage partagés ont une augmentation
substantielle
l'augmentation du poids n'a dit ce n'est
pas la façon la plus juste c'est pour ça
que nous avons choisi dans un contexte
compliqué d'augmenter ceux qui sont le
plus près du smic
plus d'un million de personnes pour à
peu près 500 euros par an tout ça sur
deux années parce qu'il nous semblait
qu'il fallait effectivement encourager
nos agents je pense à ceux qui sont dans
les ehpad ceux qui font la vie
quotidienne des uns ou des autres
premier point second point on parlait
aussi
de leur anxiété ce n'est pas la même
politique
madame la sénatrice parce que détruire
entre guillemets détruire 30 mille
emplois par an ou bien décider comme le
président de la république et le premier
ministre avait fait en juin 2012 de
rester à aix pectives constants c'est
effectivement très différent prendre la
décision de donner 60000 postes de plus
à l'éducation nationale pour répondre à
ce que vous avez dit en particulier
concernant des écoles prendre la
décision d'augmenter le nombre de
fonctionnaires de police de justice et
des pôles emploi c'est effectivement une
politique différente aujourd'hui nous
sommes tous dans une situation difficile
vous l'avez dit les fonctionnaires sont
effectivement ce qui porte les valeurs
républicaines ce qu'ils font l'action
publique et qui faisant l'action
publique font aussi le redressement de
la france vous avez parfaitement raison
une négociation va s'ouvrir sur les
traitements les parcours professionnels
les mobilités les passerelles d'une
fonction publique à une autre ce qui les
inquiète beaucoup je suis absolument
certaine que nos agents mérite
effectivement beaucoup d'attention ce
vous remercier de votre question on
partage leur anxiété on ne peut pas
répondre à toutes leurs demandes
merci la parole à pierre yves collombat
pour le groupe rdse
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des finances monsieur le
ministre le conseil des ministres des
finances de la zone euro du 5 mai
dernier semble avoir acté le principe de
la mise en place d'une taxe sur les
transactions financières à l'échelon de
11 pays comme en écho vous disiez il ya
peu je vous cite le serpent est en train
de sortir de l'eau les mines le ministre
des finances allemandes ayant déclaré à
l'issue de ce même conseil nous avons un
accord politique pour poursuivre sous
entendu nous n'avons pas d'accord sur le
fond ma première question sera quand
peut-on espérer voir la queue du serpent
la seconde à quoi va ressembler l'animal
autrement dit quels seront les produits
financiers concernés par la taxe
uniquement un panier d'actions comme
c'est le cas de la taxe française toutes
les actions et toutes les obligations
seulement les produits dérivés aussi ce
qui serait logique puisqu'il représente
aujourd'hui l'essentiel des transactions
et certainement pas les plus utiles
ainsi selon la banque des règlements
internationaux sur les sur les 700 mille
milliards il faut faire un effort pour
le lire sept cent mille milliards de
dollars des changes par an de ses
produits 7% à 8% seulement servent à
l'économie réelle enfin quel serait le
taux de la taxe les produits dérivés
spéculatifs
s'ils sont taxés le seront ils plus que
les actions et les obligations
ce qui encore une fois serait logique
est de nature à renforcer la stabilité
du système financier
merci monsieur michel sapin ministres
des finances et des comptes publics
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
monsieur le sénateur merci de cette
question qui va me permettre de préciser
pour que chacun ici en ait conscience ce
qui s'est passé exactement dans ce
conseil européen je crois important non
pas définitif car il ya encore du chemin
à faire mais cela faisait des mois pour
ne pas dire des années qu'au conseil des
ministres européens on parlait de la
mise en place d'une hypothétique taxe
sur les transactions financières il a
été enfin décidé de mettre en place un
premier temps un premier moment une
première étape mais une étape importante
que je vais vous préciser dans la mise
en oeuvre d'une telle taxe sur les
transactions financières revenons à tout
petit peu en arrière aujourd'hui il nous
faut plus de croissance il nous faut
rechercher de l'investissement et de
l'emploi supplémentaire mais on ne doit
jamais oublier
où était la cause l'origine de la crise
financière de 2008-2009 qui nous a
frappés avec ses conséquences et ses
conséquences sociales les plus terribles
l'instabilité financière l'utilisation
de manière abusive d'un certain nombre
d'outils financiers que vous avez décrit
dans des conditions qui n'avait plus
rien à voir avec l'économie réelle et
qui n'était plus que de la spéculation
sur la spéculation complètement détachée
de toute réalité c'est ça
l'origine de la catastrophe et c'est
donc à cela qu'il faut pouvoir
s'attaquer la taxe sur les transactions
financières est un des outils qui nous
permettent de mettre la régulation de
mettre un peu de sagesse dans des
mouvements de fonds financiers qui sont
par ailleurs nécessaire dès lors qu'ils
sont maîtrisés de quoi s'agit-il sans
reprendre votre image du bestiaire
sortie du loch ness quelle est la forme
de ce qui a été décidé par onze pays qui
sont pas n'importe quel pays l'allemagne
la france l'espagne l'italie portugal la
grèce et d'autres l'autriche la belgique
la hollande et d'autres pays encore il a
été décidé premièrement que le 1er
janvier 2016 la taxe serait en vigueur
c'est la première fois que nous décidons
d'une date précise il a été décidé
deuxièmement que évidemment les
transactions sur les actions devraient
être concernées c'est déjà le cas dans
notre pays et dans un seau nombre
d'autres pays mais que ça ne pouvait pas
en rester aux seules actions et il y
aura donc des produits dérivés ce que
vous avez décrit qui seront dès la
première étape dans cette taxe sur les
transactions financières quant au toît
même il faut continuer à débattre avec
l'ensemble des pays concernés onze pays
sur l'ensemble de ceux de l'union
européenne oui je suis favorable pour ma
part à ce qu'il puisse y avoir des
différenciations en termes de taux en
fonction de la dangerosité intrinsèque
des instruments qui sont utilisés merci
la parole à christian cambon pour le
groupe ump
merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre du
budget en l'absence du ministre de la
défense ce n'était qu'une rumeur et cela
risque de devenir une réalité cinq mois
seulement après le vote de la loi de
programmation militaire le gouvernement
va-t-il renier une fois de plus ses
propres engagements plutôt que de
conduire les réformes de fond
nécessaires au redressement de notre
pays c'est le budget de la défense et
des forces armées que bercy souhaite
ponctionner peut-être pour plus de 2
milliards
pourtant il s'agissait d'une promesse
solennelle du président de la république
encore le 28 mars dernier de sauvegarder
ses 31 milliards 4 annuel qui représente
déjà une diminution de crédit
considérable
un compromis tout juste acceptable pour
conserver nos forces dans l'état aucune
administration n'a en effet supporter un
tel effort cette année 2014 60% des
suppressions de postes dans la fonction
publique ont frappé nos armées qui ne
représente pourtant que 10% de cette
fonction publique les résultats on
commence à les mesurer bien sûr il ya le
retard des programmes et des livraisons
d'équipements qui risque un jour de
porter atteinte à notre sécurité
nationale mais il y a tout aussi
inquiétant le moral et la sécurité des
femmes et des hommes que nous les
politiques nous envoyons au nom de la
paix dans des pays où la violence et la
barbarie sont quotidiennes en mission en
centrafrique auprès des forces sans
garris nous les sénateurs de plusieurs
sensibilités
nous avons bien sûr pu rendre hommage au
courage et à l'abnégation de nos soldats
qui assurent par plus de 35 degrés une
mission périlleuse sans jamais se
plaindre mais nous avons vu aussi des
campements rudimentaire le rationnement
de l'eau potable des matériels vétustes
ou inadaptée des flaques d'eau et de la
boue dans les camps propice aux pas lui
qui a déjà frappé nos troupes la
situation internationale qui s'aggrave
chaque jour nous permettent elles de
baisser la garde au moment où le monde
entier réarme ou de kiev au nigeria les
tensions s'amplifient l'europe elle
le fort mais elles des armes elle laisse
la france seule dans ses missions
périlleuses le président de la
république peut certes convoqué tous les
soul tous les sommets sur la sécurité du
monde en la matière on le sait le droit
sans la force ça ne sert à rien la syrie
et l'ukraine sont là pour nous le
rappeler alors monsieur le ministre
allez vous renoncer définitivement à
cette nouvelle saignée budgétaire qui
cette fois ci mettra en péril les
capacités minimales de mobilisation de
nos armées et la cohérence de notre
défense et si vous persistiez dans vos
intentions aurez-vous alors l'honnêteté
de dire que la france n'a plus la force
de porter dans le monde les valeurs de
paix que nos militaires incarne avec
tant de courage
merci la parole à michel sapin
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur il est bien
légitime que vous vous posiez des
questions et que vous me posiez à moi
ministre des finances vous auriez voulu
le faire au ministre de la défense que
je me permets d'excusés pour son absence
il a répondu à une question de même
nature hier à l'assemblée nationale mais
il est bien naturel je puisse te faire
devant vous que les choses soient
claires il y à une loi de programmation
militaire elle a été votée aucune
inscription dans les années qui viennent
ne peut s'abstraire cette loi de
programmation militaire toute évolution
s'inscrira dans le cas de cette loi de
programmation des crédits militaires
c'est normal il faut de la visibilité
dans ce domaine là comme dans beaucoup
d'autres sinon qu'est ce que ça voudrait
dire que de lancer tel ou tel programme
si cette visibilité vient à manquer
deuxième chose
les crédits militaires ne sont pas des
crédits comme d'autres d'ailleurs vous
le décrivez comme tels ils permettent
d'assurer la sécurité la sécurité de la
france la sécurité des français parfois
en intervenant à l'extérieur parce que
c'est parfois à l'extérieur que l'on
protège les populations extérieures
c'est le cas au mali ce peut être le cas
en centrafrique c'est peut être le cas
encore ailleurs et par là même où
protège aussi la sécurité des français
en luttant contre le terrorisme contre
leur base et donc c'est vrai on ne peut
pas parler de ces crédits comme de tout
autre crédit ils ont une spécificité
particulier les gens parlent toujours de
cette manière là et je ne les considère
jamais comme des crédits exactement de
même nature que d'autres mais monsieur
le sénateur
aujourd'hui comme hier
il faut aussi maîtriser nos dépenses
publiques aujourd'hui comme hier et
d'ailleurs hier c'est souvent vous
l'avez voter vous même les lois de
programmation militaire qui ont servi de
valeur d'ajustement donc aujourd'hui
comme hier il faut que nous maîtrisions
la dépense je pense qu'il est d'accord
les uns et les autres ici pour dire que
cette maîtrise de la dépense publique
est absolument nécessaire et on ne peut
pas abstraire un ministère
indépendamment de telle ou telle mission
de tout effort il n'est pas question il
n'est pas question pour reprendre les
images que vous preniez qu'il y est un
euro de moins je pense même qu'il faut d
euros de plus pour nos militaires
engagés pour ceux qui sont au contact
pour ceux qui risquent de donner leur
vie pour ceux qui ont parfois donné leur
vie il ne peut pas être question de cela
vous savez bien que les crédits
militaires sont beaucoup plus vaste que
cela et qu'on ne peut pas non plus dire
qu'il n'ya aucun effort à faire mais je
voudrais terminer par une phrase qui
était une très belle phrase du ministre
de la défense nationale hier nous
voulons protéger la souveraineté de la
france la protection de la souveraineté
et de la sécurité de la france elle
passe par nos crédits nos crédits
militaires nous prédire qui assure la
sécurité intérieure et extérieure
mais l'autre souveraineté elle passe
aussi par notre souveraineté budgétaire
et financière et par la maîtrise de nos
finances publiques
merci la parole à jean marie bockel pour
le groupe udi uc merci monsieur le
président votre réponse monsieur le
ministre sapin le nous rassure guère
madame la ministre la rationalisation
de notre millefeuille territorial
constitue une revendication historique
des centristes mais nous demeurons à ce
stade vigilant et critique vis-à-vis de
votre projet de réforme territoriale et
surtout de votre méthode en effet après
moult déclarations présidentielles et
gouvernementales
force est de constater que c'est le flou
et l'incertitude qui prévalent
aujourd'hui il est temps pour le
gouvernement de sortir des non dits et
dépositions successives à un rythme
d'ailleurs accéléré pour nous trois
objectifs indissociables doivent être
poursuivis premièrement cette réforme
doit conduire à une meilleure gestion de
nos dépenses publiques en générant des
économies avérée notamment sur les frais
de fonctionnement en favorisant la
suppression des doublons arrêtons
cependant madame la ministre les
discours incantatoires ponctuée de
milliards sorti du chapeau car c'est de
réalisme et de sérieux dont nous avons
besoin pour mener à bien cette
rationalisation de nos dépenses
deuxièmement cette réforme territoriale
doit permettre de gagner en lisibilité
en efficacité à travers une
clarification des compétences des
différents des différents échelons
territoriaux
c'est ce que nos compatriotes attendent
afin de redonner du sens à la démocratie
locale mettre sur pied des régions et
des intercommunalités plus forte pour
gagner en attractivité est une chose
mais quelles seront leurs compétences et
pour quelle relation entre elles
finalement cette réforme doit être
l'occasion de remettre notre pays en
mouvement en dynamisant nos territoires
il faut permettre collectivités locales
de développer tout leur potentiel pour
qu'elle pèse en europe et dans la
mondialisation et pour qu'elles génèrent
de la croissance et de la solidarité
madame la ministre si les objectifs de
la réforme sont essentiels le calendrier
et la méthode ne le sont pas moins à cet
égard je précise d'emblée que nous nous
opposons fermement à l'idée de retarder
les élections cantonales et régionales
de mars prochain alors que celles ci ont
déjà été reportée d'une année cette
réforme
structurelle est trop importante à nos
yeux pour servir de prétexte à un
changement de calendrier électoral à des
fins partisanes pour ce qui est de la
méthode pour ce qui est de la méthode il
peut y avoir de réponse uniforme est
toute prête à des réalités territoriales
diverses ainsi comme président de mon
admiration à mulhouse je suis convaincu
de l'élargissement progressif des
intercommunalités vers la notion de
bassin de vie mais alors que la france
vient tout juste d'achever sa carte
intercommunale il convient d'adapter
cette nouvelle réforme à la diversité de
nos territoires d'autant que le critère
de population ne peut s'appliquer de la
même manière sur un territoire rural et
serait territoires urbanisés sur cet
aspect et sur d'autres comme le devenir
des jetons départementale nous attendons
de vous du pragmatisme madame le
ministre gouvernement est il prêt à
engager avec les élus une réforme
ambitieuse et durable selon un
calendrier raisonnable
méthodologie appropriée j'espère que les
consultations aux coûts réalisées seront
entendus comme vous le savez nous
incarnons une opposition constructive
mais je vous le dis madame la ministre
quand il ya du flou il ya un loup ne
comptez pas sur les parlementaires
centristes pour hec un chat un chat en
sac merci
la parole à monsieur le premier ministre
c'est le président en présentant mes
excuses à madame lebranchu et afin de
vous répondre sur une question qui est
importante et en essayant monsieur le
ministre de ne pas polémiquer et votre
conclusion malheureusement enlevait la
qualité de votre première partie parce
que précisément sur ces sujets là je
pense vous l'avez dit qu'il faut être
sérieux et être capable de poser les
problèmes il y à une attente d'une
réforme profonde de nos collectivités
territoriales de ce que vous avez appelé
le mille feuille territorial et cette
réforme on en parle mais on ne la fait
pas la gauche a accompli au cours de
cette année en année des réformes
des deux décentralisations
particulièrement importantes avec pierre
mauroy et gaston defferre avec jean
pierre chevènement et dominique voynet
il ya eu aussi des étapes de
décentralisation avec jean pierre
raffarin mais chacun reconnaît
aujourd'hui que nous avons perdu en
efficacité et en lisibilité et toute
réforme de nos collectivités
territoriales ou de l'état puisque les
deux doivent aller de pair nous en avons
beaucoup parlé ce matin en réunion des
ministres doivent permettre l'efficacité
de la dépense publique et aussi par
rapport à la fiscalité la solidarité
entre les territoires et je pense
notamment aux territoires ruraux ou
territoires urbains qui sont qui vit
avec ce sentiment d'abandon que nous
avons tous constaté au cours de ces
dernières années et puis bien sûr la
démocratie la proximité et pour cela il
faut aller vite et dans toute
proposition qui consiste à perdre du
temps où à différer cette réforme il ya
évidemment une intention de ne pas la
faire et le président la république est
en train de consulter les responsables
politiques il en tira évidemment un
certain nombre de conclusions mais
l'idée est bien d'organiser notre pays
autour de grandes régions de solidifier
l'intercommunalité et nous aurons
évidemment ce débat et plus
particulièrement au sénat de travailler
sur la question des compétences et le
texte sur lequel travaille marylise
lebranchu et andré vallini et d'entamer
dans d'organiser la disparition des
conseils généraux touche la pause nous
le savons toute une série de problèmes
mais latente de réforme la tante de
changement elle elle ne saurait être
contestée et surtout entraves et nous
devons le faire dans un dialogue ne sera
pas forcément toujours facile il y aura
des confrontations c'est normal mais
tout ce qu'ils ont proposé ici ou
ailleurs sur tous les bancs soit la
disparition des départements ce qu'on
parlait de cela soit la réduction des
régions il y a un rapport sénatorial qui
fait foi ici tout cela tout cela
monsieur bockel ils devront dire s'ils
sont oui ou non pour la réforme avec des
questions difficiles compliquées qui
concerne les compétences qui concerne
les compétences qui concerne la dgf qui
concerne les solidarité indispensable de
notre pays et nous devrons nous et c'est
la responsabilité de mon gouvernement
compagne et cela je vous dis un instant
par une réforme profonde de l'état parce
que c'est l'occasion aussi de le faire
et alors on verra là monsieur bockel qui
est droit dans ses bottes qui est
capable de réformer qui est capable
d'être au coeur de ses convictions qui
est capable d'être clair par rapport au
pays je vous attends vous et tous les
autres sur ce sujet là
merci
merci la parole à simon sutour pour le
groupe socialiste
sur le président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à harlem désir
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes
que je salue tout particulièrement dans
dix jours l'europe connaîtra des moments
clés de sa construction l'élection au
suffrage universel des 751 députés du
parlement européen pour un mandat de
cinq ans par 400 millions de citoyens
européens
cette élection comporte en elle même
deux enjeux qui font de ce vote est un
acte citoyen majeur aller voter le 25
mai prochain c'est dire quelle europe on
souhaite aller voter le 25 mai prochain
c'est donner du poids au parlement
européen pour qu'il puisse se défendre
cette europe
le parlement européen a beaucoup évolué
depuis l'entrée en vigueur du traité de
lisbonne en 2009 qui lui a conféré de
nouveaux pouvoirs de codécision en
matière de protection des consommateurs
d'agriculture de protection des données
personnelles de transport
d'environnement de dépenses budgétaires
et d'approbation des accords commerciaux
les citoyens dans veut faire revivre ses
pouvoirs à leur donner tout leur sens
plus nouveau rompu le parlement européen
aura de poids dans les décisions
européennes
ce scrutin du 25 mai sera également un
scrutin historique car pour la première
fois par leur vote les citoyens
européens peineront directement sur le
choix du président de la commission
européenne qui devra être issu des rangs
de la majorité dégager au parlement
européen le saut démocratique est
considérable d'abord en termes de
proximité
mes chers collègues comment aurait-on pu
imaginer avant cette campagne que le
chef de file des socialistes européens
martin schulz pour ces élections au
parlement européen et candidat à la
présidence de la commission européenne
puisse se rencontrer les anciens
salariés des abattoirs gad dans le
finistère et leur expliquer comment il
compte concrètement poursuivre son
action pour lutter contre le dumping
social et faire en sorte que les droits
sociaux soient reconnus de la même
manière que les libertés économiques
mais aussi mes chers collègues en termes
de légitimité après dix ans d'une europe
où gouverner à droite nous pouvons
choisir le 25 mai en parlement européen
est un président de la commission qui
soit plus favorable aux attentes des
citoyens européens touchés par la crise
à nos orientations et à nos ambitions
pour l'europe une europe qui défendent
des politiques alternatives à
l'austérité qui protègent mieux les
droits sociaux les libertés
fondamentales qui investit plusieurs
matchs en particulier dans la lutte
contre le chômage et les déséquilibres
économiques et qui plaide pour
l'harmonisation fiscale
la semaine prochaine il ne s'agira pas
de dire si on vote pour ou contre
l'europe l'europe elle existe elle tisse
organise notre quotidien c'est de savoir
pour quelle europe
les décisions prises comme on dit à
bruxelles ce ne sont pas celles d'un
quelconque pouvoir invisible ce sont
celles du parlement européen et des
états membres élus par les citoyens et
leur orientation politique n'est pas
indifférente aux choix qui seront faits
pour l'europe monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous nous indiquer à ce moment
essentiel de la vie démocratique
européenne quels sont les grands
principes qui président à l'action
européenne du gouvernement merci la
parole à monsieur harlem désir
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur sutour nous sommes
effectivement à dix jours d'un scrutin
décisif pour l'avenir de l'europe pour
l'avenir de la france en europe l'europe
c'est non seulement un héritage précieux
que nous ont laissé les père fondateur
celui de la paix et nous allons dans
quelques semaines commémorait les débuts
de la grande guerre et son centenaire
nous allons célébrer le 70e anniversaire
du débarquement nous voyons les troubles
aux frontières même de l'union
européenne
nous ne pouvons pas négliger et
dilapider cet acquis fondamental grâce à
l'europe depuis maintenant plusieurs
décennies notre continent et ses états
membres vivent en paix mais l'europe
c'est aujourd'hui surtout l'échelon
indispensable dont nous avons besoin
pour agir dans la mondialisation les
principes de l'action du gouvernement ce
sont ceux dont nous souhaitons que la
forte mobilisation des français au
scrutin du 25 mai permettent de les
renforcer pour que la voix de la france
soit entendu
europe pour que la réorientation que
nous avons souhaitée vers des politiques
de soutien à la croissance à l'emploi
parce que vous l'avez dit nous ne
pensons pas que l'austérité puisse être
une réponse à la situation de notre
continent pour que cette voix de la
france puisse peser plus fort demain en
europe parce que nous ne voulons pas non
plus que les populistes que les
nationalistes que ceux qui vont qui
veulent défaire la construction
européenne puisse l'emporter de ce
scrutin alors les principes de notre
action et bien c'est d'abord je les dis
renforcer les politiques de soutien la
croissance les politiques
d'investissements dans les grands
domaines d'avenir le numérique l'énergie
les transports les télécommunications et
nous voulons une europe qui défendent
nos industries et nous mêmes nous avons
pris aujourd'hui une décision c'est le
décret qui a été signé par le premier
ministre et le ministre de l'économie
pour défendre nos industries nous
voulons bâtir des industries européennes
dans les domaines d'avenir deuxièmement
nous ne voulons pas que l'europe soit
seulement un marché nous ne voulons pas
d'une europe du dumping social et vous
avez eu raison de rappeler l'accord
important que nous avons réussi à
obtenir sur les travailleurs détachés
nous voulons l'alignement des droits
sociaux vers le haut nous voulons une
europe qui se dote d'un salaire minimum
dans tous les pays nous voulons que les
mêmes règles sociales les mêmes
protections sociales soit acquise et
soit assurée pour tous les travailleurs
en europe enfin l'europe demain ce doit
être l'europe de l'énergie pour assurer
à la fois la sécurité des
approvisionnements mais aussi pour
assurer la transition énergétique pour
que l'europe reste pionnière en matière
d'énergies renouvelables en matière de
technologies vertes enfin pour que
l'europe pèse dans le monde il nous
faudra construire cette europe de la
défense dont nous avons besoin c'est
aussi une europe industriels mais c'est
d'abord une europe de la solidarité pour
défendre nos valeurs et pour défendre la
pêche aux leurres merci
merci merci
la parole est à court in blue pour le
groupe écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il semble
que le rapport préliminaire de la cour
des comptes évoqués par le quotidien les
échos sur la gestion d'areva pour la
période 2006 2012 pose diverses
questions à la fois concernant la
gouvernance et concernant un certain
nombre de choix stratégique à moyen et
long terme quand on connaît les méthodes
extrêmement minutieuse de la cour des
comptes respect du contradictoire que
les réalités
comprenez que les mots que l'on a pu
voir dans la presse ils sont vérifiés
sont extrêmement inquiétant
au delà d'une personne sur laquelle nous
n'avons pas d'avis à donner nous
voudrions savoir monsieur le ministre
quel est votre point de vue actuel quant
à la situation d'areva des choix
stratégiques qui ont été faits dont
certains sont pour le moins malheureux
notamment la sphère ura mines au canada
et je profite de cette opportunité pour
vous rappeler que nous sommes
extrêmement attachés à la réduction
sensible la place du nucléaire et nous
nous demandons si cette remise en cause
du modèle areva n'est finalement pas une
opportunité pour envisager un certain
nombre de remises en cause quant aux
choix stratégiques d'arriva je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre de
répondre à nos inquiétudes et j'espère
qu'au plan technologique les choses sont
plus sûrs qu au niveau managérial en
matière de nucléaire je vous remercie
merci pour vous répondre arnaud
montebourg ministre d'économie du
redressement productif et du numérique
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs m la sénatrice
corinne bouchoux il est exact qu'un
rapport final de la cour sera publiée
d'ici fin juin aux termes d'ailleurs
d'un processus habituel très codifié le
contrôle sur toutes les entreprises
publiques donc la conclusion définitive
n'est pas maintenant il s'agit d'une
conclusion provisoire à laquelle les
intéressés ont eu à répondre et à
l'issue de cette procédure cette navette
nous aurons une conclusion définitive le
contrôle a été réalisé en 2013 a porté
sur les exercices 2006 2012 d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des intéressés depuis l'
agence des participations de l'état qui
est sous l'autorité de michel sapin et
moi-même la direction
de l'industrie où les dirigeants d'areva
de l'époque ont pu faire part de leurs
commentaires
je voudrais peut-être répondre à vos
interrogations notamment sur la
gouvernance du groupe car en effet de
nombreuses réflexions ont été initiées
par mes services nous mêmes et les deux
principaux actionnaires que sont le
commissariat à l'énergie atomique et aux
énergies alternatives et l'état comptent
envoyer il ya deux semaines au président
du directoire et au président du conseil
de surveillance un courrier leur
demandant de lancer la procédure de
transformation d'areva en société à
conseil d'administration
il s'agit d'une transformation
importante car elle permettra aux
actionnaires de contrôler davantage et
le faire passer devant le conseil
d'administration
un certain nombre de ces décisions
stratégiques qu'elles concernent les
mines qu'elle concerne les alliances
qu'elle concerne les rachats ou les
défaisance c'est un point important car
nous avons eu à connaître un certain
nombre de frustrations en la matière ou
le conseil de surveillance ne pouvait
pas intervenir dans les décisions
stratégiques de l'entreprise
s'agissant de la sphère ura ming avait
cité les enquêtes sont en cours nous
souhaitons attendre les résultats quant
à la situation financière d'areva sur
laquelle vous nous interroger la
sénatrice les perspectives des marchés
nucléaires sont amoindries à court et
moyen terme notamment en raison du
redémarrage plus lent que prévu des
centrales japonaises néanmoins le
gouvernement japonais a fait part de son
désir publiquement de redémarrer et donc
de redonner à ses capacités de
production d'origine électrique
d'origine nucléaire c'est étrange de
centrales nucléaires peut-être que au
delà de 2016 à la fin d'une période
d'investissement très important pour le
groupe areva areva est en mesure de
retrouver des marges de manoeuvre
financières significatives
bien sûr si il y à stabilisation des
conditions du marché du nucléaire à cet
horizon je voudrais signaler qu areva et
participants d'un certain nombre
d'investissements à l'étranger très
important c'est la victoire en turquie
sur atmea la participation sur inc
l'épaule en grande bretagne car des
états aujourd'hui investissent avec
areva dans le nucléaire
merci
la parole est à catherine tremblay pour
le groupe ump
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur le ministre au départ
l'histoire des rythmes scolaires c'est
celle d'un consensus une journée d'école
trop longue et une année scolaire trop
courte la réforme était donc souhaitable
même si elle n'était pas prioritaire
alors comment sommes nous arriver à de
tel mécontentement
la faute de votre prédécesseur
qui deux duos de l'état enfermé dans son
bureau rue de grenelle a cru qu'il
pouvait en claquant des doigts
bouleversée l'école pensées mes chers
collègues que le ministre peillon n'a
pas pris la peine de venir défendre sa
réforme devant le parlement
ni même de se déplacer devant la mission
d'information de madame cartron élus
socialistes était le rapporteur il a
préféré la décréter seul entouré de
quelques technocrates
alors monsieur hamon vous êtes le
ministre qui doit renouer le dialogue
le décret du 8 mai présente des avancées
certaines mais l'interrogent et est très
absent insuffisant voire
contre-productif le premier décret
plaidé pour une réduction de la durée
d'enseignement journalières et vous
offrez la possibilité de la rétablir à 6
heures le premier décret plaidé pour une
répartition des activités périscolaires
sur l'ensemble de la semaine et votre
décret offre la possibilité de les
concentrer sur une demi-journée avec le
risque avéré que ce soit sur le vendredi
après midi ce qui rallongera davantage
encore la rupture du week end par
ailleurs les communes qui n'arriveront
pas à résoudre les difficultés
financières qu'elle rencontre ne
mettront pas en place d'activités ce
périscolaire vous aurez alors deux types
d'écoliers les écoliers du périscolaire
et les orphelins de 15 heures
cette situation aussi cette situation
aussi est contraire à l'esprit de la
réforme monsieur le ministre où se
trouve véritablement l'intérêt de
l'enfant
enfin vous prenez un décret le 8 mai et
vous exigez moins d'un mois après que la
nouvelle organisation sera présenté au
daz n nous sommes dans la précipitation
la plus totale
monsieur le ministre un moratoire
s'impose jusqu'à la rentrée 2015 car une
telle réforme doit être subordonnée au
vote préalable d'une loi qui garantira
l'intérêt premier qui est celui de
l'enfant et créera une véritable
dotation de compensation pérenne bon
prenant en compte le coût réel au regard
des besoins des collectivités
monsieur le ministre quelles sont les
solutions que vous comptez mettre en
oeuvre pour répondre à toutes ces
exigences
merci la parole à monsieur benoit mans
ministres éducation nationale
enseignement supérieur recherche merci
monsieur le sénateur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame là cette
année à trice
vous êtes inscrit les uns et les autres
et vous l'avez dit vous-même dans la
volonté à partir d'un diagnostic qui
avaient été posées par tous
de réorganiser les rythmes éducatif de
façon à ce qu'ils soient davantage
adaptée aux rythmes de l'enfant
c'était le diagnostic posé par mon
prédécesseur vincent peillon mais aussi
le sien luc chatel nous savons tous
aujourd'hui
que les résultats de notre école
primaire recule pourquoi parce que les
apprentissages fondamentaux aux
mathématiques et en français se font
moins bien nous savons pourquoi
parce que les journées sont trop longues
notamment et qu'il manque une matinée à
tous ces enfants pour faire en sorte que
lors de leur pic de vigilance entre 9h
et 11h ils apprennent mieux il fallait
donc que nous bâtissions les rythmes
scolaires différemment c'est le sens de
cette réforme elle a posé à travers un
premier décret neuf demi journées dont
cinq matinées et elle propose à travers
le décret que je vous hais
proposée qui a été publié des
dérogations des expérimentations de
façon à tenir compte davantage d'un
certain nombre des remarques que vous
vous aviez fait
aujourd'hui nous maintenons cet objectif
qui est de permettre aux enfants de
mieux apprendre parce que je veux le
dire comme ministre de l'éducation
nationale quelle est ma responsabilité
celle que m'a confié le premier ministre
de faire en sorte que la france ne soit
plus la championne d'europe pour le
poids de l'origine sociale dans le
destin scolaire des enfants or nous
savons
nous savons qu'en permettant aux enfants
de travailler une matinée de plus nous
leur permettrons de mieux appréhender
route de retrouver quelque chose auquel
nous sommes tous attachés le goût du
travail le goût d'apprendre c'est à cela
que je veux travailler et c'est ma
responsabilité
vous me jugerez vous nous jugera dans
deux ou trois ans sur le niveau de nos
enfants en sortie de cm2 oui dans deux
ou trois ans pardon parce que mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs l'éducation
c'est le temps long et l'éducation c'est
le temps long si long que maintenant
quand même au bout de dix ans nous
sommes en capacité de mesurer ce qui a
été l'impact d'une politique qui
consistait à diminuer le nombre de
professeurs dans les écoles mais je vais
vous dire au passage si c'est le
problème que cette année à la rentrée il
y aura dans le haut-rhin des postes
supplémentaires ceci vous le devez à la
gauche qu'il a permis qui a inversé une
logique qui était une logique de recul
des effectifs mais je veux dire aussi
que je réponde j'ai répondu un certain
nombre des remarques qui ont été faits
de lordat mission d'information vous
nous avez demandé de mieux tenir compte
des maternelles nous l'avons fait mieux
tenir compte des communes rurales nous
le faisons en permettant de concentrer
le temps périscolaire sur une après midi
c'était votre recommandation maintenant
vous nous dites le décret
complémentaires et contre productif
alors qu'il répond à vos demandes
j'ajoute que vous nous avez demandé de
prolonger d'une année supplémentaire
le fonds d'amorçage le premier ministre
l'a décidé
si vous choisissez aujourd'hui de
changer d'avis je le regrette parce que
ce n'est pas l'intérêt de l'enfant merci
la parole à françoise cartron pour le
groupe socialiste
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale il hier les 18 propositions
contenues dans le rapport de la mission
sénatoriale d'information sur les
rythmes scolaires ont été rejetées suite
à une mane suite à une manoeuvre que je
qualifierais de grossières menée par le
groupe ump ces 18 propositions
constituaient pourtant autant de
réponses aux difficultés ou
interrogation recueillies durant les six
mois de travail de la mission est invité
validé par la présidente d'un d'entre
eux ne l'est d'ailleurs lundi dernier en
déplacement en haute savoie à votre
demande monsieur karl malone tremblay
vous même vous êtes félicité du dernier
décret de monsieur le ministre qui selon
vous aller dans le bon sens saluant le
projet innovant de la ville de megève
vous aviez d'ailleurs largement convié
la presse locale qui s'en est fait écho
est de retour au sénat mercredi volte
face désormais tout est à rejeter on ne
sait même plus ce que vous voulez si ce
n'est détruire et démolir cette réforme
reconnu indispensable pour tous il faut
dire que cette tâche de démolition de
l'école publique vous l'avez entreprises
depuis dix ans bientôt et avec une
véritable constance
suppression des trois heures
d'enseignement merci monsieur darcos -
d'école pour mieux apprendre c'est
évident suppression des 80 mille postes
merci monsieur sarkozy - deux frères
pour plus d'enfants c'est évident
suppression de la formation des
enseignants merci monsieur chatel loin
de formation pour mieux enseigner c'est
toujours aussi évident il s'agit de bien
mauvaise manière qu'ils prennent en
otage l'intérêt des enfants avant de
servir une cause politicienne sans doute
largement élaboré par saintais mentor de
l'ump oui merci monsieur copé la réalité
est tout autre tout au long de nos et
placement et de nos auditions nous avons
rencontré des acteurs motivés et
satisfait par cette nouvelle
organisation du temps scolaire saluant
déjà les effets positifs pour les
enfants bien loin du tableau
apocalyptique adressées par certains
alors monsieur le ministre je vous
demande de nous réaffirmer votre
position pour la prochaine rentrée
scolaire car aujourd'hui une entreprise
de désinformation est à nouveau activé
semant le doute dans l'esprit de
beaucoup de parents et de beaucoup
d'enseignants tout ceci dans l'intérêt
des enfants bien évidemment merci
la parole à monsieur ministre benoît
hamon
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
bon vous m'interrogez sur la mise en
oeuvre de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires à la rentrée moi je veut
distinguer deux types de situation il y
a les situations que l'on peut régler
parce que celles et ceux qui nous
demandent de travail et veulent les
régler puis des postures qui sont des
postures qui sont inévitables dans le
débat public et qui amène un certain
nombre d'élus à vouloir s'opposer à la
mise en oeuvre de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires il ya deux manières de
s'opposer celle sincère argumenté qui
consiste à contester par exemple le sens
et le bien fondé de cette réforme et ça
je les accepte évidemment puis celle que
je n'accepte pas qui consiste à dire
nous nous affranchir ont de la règle
parce qu'on ne peut pas s'affranchir de
la règle est ce que vous n'avez pas dit
même traîné je vous le redis je le
reconnais et je vous en remercie on ne
peut pas surtout en tant que
parlementaire d'hier la règle on peut
s'en affranchir la loi on peut s'en
affranchir mais je vous dis de surcroît
que
l'organisation des temps éducatif sur le
principe du décret qui a été publiée par
monsieur peillon et par moi-même
s'appliquera évidemment à la rentrée à
toutes les villes et à tous les enfants
pourquoi parce que je le redis le temps
scolaire c'est l'état il nous revient
désormais de travailler encore et encore
avec les communes qui ont des
difficultés à l'organisation du temps
périscolaire que nous on dit un certain
nombre de communes rural la difficulté
pour elle surtout pour de nouvelles
équipes municipales qui avaient trouvé
peu de travail fait avant avant elle et
ça existe la difficulté pour elle de
penser une organisation efficace du
temps périscolaire dès lors que ce sont
des communes de petite taille et que la
réflexion n'avait pas existé auparavant
nous leur avons proposé d'aménager sous
la forme d'une expérimentation la mise
en oeuvre des nouveaux rythmes éducatif
en permettant de concentrer les
activités périscolaires sur une après
midi on me dit mais vous libérer une
demi journée le vendredi après midi pour
les enseignants on peut pas me demander
à la fois de vouloir faciliter le
travail des communes rurales en
permettant que sur certaines
intercommunalités on libère le lundi
après midi dans la ville x le mardi
après midi dans la ville y le jeudi
après midi dans la ville a et le
vendredi après midi dans la ville b et
ainsi travailler à concentrer des
activités périscolaires avec les mêmes
intervenants de qualité qualifié en
diminuant les coûts on ne peut pas me
demander cela et ensuite me reprocher de
faire soit disant un cadeau aux
enseignants vous nous avez demandé de
travailler sur les maternelles vrai
sujet le périscolaire dans les
maternelles ce n'est pas pareil que dans
le primaire la circulaire qui accompagne
le décret tient compte de cela je le
redis l'état d'esprit du gouvernement
est de travailler à la mise en oeuvre
d'une réforme qui s'applique partout
parce que c'est la loi et qu'il revient
à l'état de fixer le temps scolaire je
suis ouvert à la discussion mais il
revient un moment où on attend du
gouvernement qu'il prenne des décisions
nous avons pris cette décision je
souhaite que vous nous accompagner dans
la mise en oeuvre d'une réforme
favorable aux enfants merci un apparent
la lynx ont cogné pour le groupe
socialiste
le président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur stéphane
le foll mis sur l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire la forêt porte parole
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre les
pensions des retraités agricoles ne sont
parmi les plus faibles de france la
situation est surtout difficile pour les
collaborateurs familiaux et les
conjoints survivants qui sont d'ailleurs
bien souvent des femmes les pensions de
retraite des non salariés agricoles sont
inférieurs de près de 40% de celles des
retraites du régime général de l'ordre
de 625 euros par mois la pension minimum
globale du chef d'exploitation pour une
carrière complète s'élève elle à 790
euros par mois soit l'équivalent de 70 8
% du smic mensuel net cette situation
plonge chaque année des milliers
d'agriculteurs dans une très forte
précarité et décourage les jeunes
générations à reprendre les exportations
le président de la république s'est
clairement engagé à mettre en oeuvre un
plan quinquennal de revel région des
retraites agricoles
avec le vote de lois garantissant
l'avenir la justice du système de
retraites plusieurs mesures fortes ainsi
ont été actés comme le portage du
montant des pensions garantie à 75% du
smic pour une carrière complète d'ici
l'extension de la retraite
complémentaire obligatoire aux conjoints
et de familiaux etc et bien d'autres
mesures au total cette revalorisation
atteindra 300 millions d'euros en 2017
dans le contexte budgétaire actuel cela
démontre l'engagement sans faille du
gouvernement aux côtés des retraités
agricoles et des retraités les plus
modestes alors que nous demandons à tous
les efforts contraint par la situation
budgétaire hérité de la majorité
précédente ces mesures constituent un
signal fort de jc sociale envers les
plus modestes et en particulier ces
femmes qui ont travaillé tant d'années
sans véritable statut
aujourd'hui 1,6 million de retraités
agricoles sont dans l'attenté des
décrets d'application de la loi sur les
retraites pourriez-vous donc confirmé
aux agriculteurs qui nous écoutent
monsieur le ministre que cela se fera
soit faite et que le gouvernement
poursuivra son action pour soutenir les
petites retraites agricoles
merci la parole à stéphane le foll mise
l'agriculture pourtant le sénateur je
voudrais répondre d'abord à cette
question importante vous l'avez rappelé
dans la campagne présidentielle un
engagement avait été pris sur la base du
constat que vous avez fait la faiblesse
la faiblesse des retraites pour les
agriculteurs qui en font les retraites
qui sont globalement les moins élevés
dans notre pays aujourd'hui il fallait
donc les revaloriser dans toutes ces
questions de valorisation il ya aussi de
poser des questions des recettes les
arbitrages qui ont été faits et je tiens
à souligner le travail qui a été conduit
avec marisol touraine sur ce dossier
dans le cadre de la réforme des
retraites ont permis de dégager les
moyens nécessaires pour revaloriser à
l'objectif fixé de 75% du smic en 2017
l'ensemble des retraites des
agriculteurs de donner des points et des
droits gratuits à ceux qui n'avaient pas
bénéficié depuis en particulier les
aides familiaux et aussi les conjointes
en agriculture qui était victime à ce
titre d'une vraie discrimination chose a
été décidée chose a été votée au mois de
janvier 2014 la question qui est posée
maintenant c'est la question des décrets
et de leurs applications et jeux
répondent aujourd'hui devant votre
assemblée que ces décrets ont été va
être publié dans les jours qui vont
venir et peut-être demain ce qui fait
qu'après le vote de la loi en janvier
quatre mois après les décrets
d'application seront publiés avec ray
audrey rétroactivité en février 2014
donc à la question posée la réponse est
claire ces décrets vont être publiés
s'appliqueront parce que l'enjeu de la
revalorisation des retraites agricoles
était un engagement il est tenu
merci la parole à antoine lefèvre dont
le groupe ump
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre les jours se suivent
sans que nous puissions vous suivre vous
pas une semaine où il ne soit question
de réforme territoriale pas une semaine
où une annonce dans annuler déjà une
autre actuellement nous avons atteint le
summum le 27 novembre 2012 annonce du
report de l'année 2001 2015 des scrutins
d' élections territoriales normalement
prévue en 2014 repoussés en 2016 nous
dit le président de la république l'on
ne sais pas en fait vraiment car
peut-être ce serait fin 2015 le temps de
modifier les régions d'ici à 2017 mais
en fait peut-être d'ici cette fin
d'année car soudain il faut accélérer le
rythme et dans tous les cas les
départements seraient dissous à
l'horizon 2021 mais peu traite mais
peut-être pardon dès 2016 bref c'est
compliqué tout cela pourtant le
président n'avait il pas affirmé en
janvier dans sa bonne ville de tulle et
je veux le site et les départements
gardent leur utilité pour assurer la
cohésion sociale la solidarité
territoriale
ajoutant écoutez bien je ne suis donc
pas favorable à leur suppression pure et
simple car des territoires ruraux
perdrait en qualité de vie sans
d'ailleurs généré d'économies
supplémentaires triple salto arrière
pour masquer encore et toujours un
énième revirement encore et toujours un
dernier à l'énième reniement le
président consulte depuis hier tous les
partis politiques
comment en effet osé espérer faire
adopter cette réforme suscite et d'un
référendum vous leurs doutes et modifier
la constitution mais avec quelle
majorité la présentation du projet de
loi initialement prévue au conseil des
ministres d'hier est reportée au 21 puis
aux 21 au 28 mai voir maintenant en juin
vous nous demandez donc de nous
positionner alors même qu'aucun contenu
ne nous est présenté quel cynisme assumé
je rappelle que la précédente majorité
avait enclenché la fusion des
départements et des régions avec la mise
en place du conseiller territorial vous
l'avez abrogé mais finalement il
semblerait que vous rallier à l'idée que
ce comté ce conseiller territorial était
plutôt une bonne idée
la clause de compétence générale des
départements et des régions pour éviter
qu'ils ne se concurrencent en permanence
avait été supprimée
vous l'avez réintroduite là où pourtant
vous aviez des gisements d'économies que
de temps perdu pourquoi n'avoir pas
examiner de plus près que le conseiller
territorial était une bonne idée avant
de le lyncher il serait à l'heure de
cette séance déjà élu et le mille
feuille territorial dont tout le monde
se plaint déjà en partie réduit et les
économies seraient lancés par ce que
vous redoutez les scrutins à venir vous
voulez tout chambouler dans la
précipitation et sans concertation vous
mettez à mal notre organisation
territoriale sans alternative crédible
nous contestons la méthode et attendons
du contenu monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres ma
question est simple où allez-vous où
allons nous je vous remercie merci vous
répandre la parole et à bernard
cazeneuve le ministre de l'intérieur
merci beaucoup monsieur le sénateur le
fait faux votre question qui permet
d'apporter un certain nombre d'éléments
de réponse précise à votre assemblée sur
la réforme territoriale mais également
la réforme de l'état d'abord vous
conviendrait monsieur le sénateur dans
cette assemblée qui a une grande
tradition de sagesse qui n'est pas
nécessaire sur l'avenir des territoires
l'avenir de notre pays le renforcement
de l'efficacité de la puissance publique
de créer sur tous les sujets
systématiquement des polémiques en
prêtant à ceux qui sont en situation de
responsabilité des pensées qu'ils n'ont
pas d'ailleurs s'il fallait considérer
qu'à chaque fois que les modes de
scrutin
change et que la date des scrutins sont
modifiées il y a une intention politique
pernicieuse vous en auriez eu beaucoup
d'intentions politiques pernicieuse au
cours des dernières décennies je veux
rappeler puisque en
1994 deux mois avant les élections
cantonales vous avez décidé de modifier
la durée du mandat des conseillers
généraux élus en mars 94 en l'allongeant
d'un an et en 2005 vous avez décidé de
modifier la durée des mandats des
conseillers généraux des conseillers
municipaux et des sénateurs sans qu'à
aucun moment des questions aux dés
anthologique vous ai traversé à l'époque
l'esprit et sans d'ailleurs que
nécessairement nous ne vous ayons prêter
de mauvaises intentions c'est pour dire
qu' il ne faut pas que ce que vous avez
fait parfois en ayant des objectifs
politiques soient prêtés à ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas d'autre que de transformer et
moderniser profondément notre pays ça
c'est le premier poids le second poids
sur lequel je voudrais vous répondre
c'est sur la réforme elle même de quoi
s'agit-il il s'agit de faire en sorte
d'avoir moins de collectivités
territoriales - pauvre davantage doté de
capacités d'intervention et
d'investissement pour moderniser notre
pays et de faire en sorte que tout cela
se fasse dans un contexte davantage
visibles pour les français qui
renforcent l'efficacité de nos
collectivités et puisque vous voulez de
la clarté permettez moi monsieur les
sénateurs de vous rappeler quels sont
les objectifs que poursuit cette réforme
territoriale un faire en sorte que nous
puissions avoir moins de régions de
dimension européenne et qui permettent
de faire en sorte que dans le trans sur
le transfert de technologie
l'accompagnement de grandes filières
d'excellence la relation entre
l'entreprise et le monde de l'université
l'investissement sur les grandes
infrastructures l'équipement numérique
du territoire nous ayons des régions
qu'ils soient de dimension européenne et
qu'ils soient plus performantes voilà ce
que nous voulons faire deuxièmement nous
voulons des intercommunalités plus forte
de manière à ce que nous puissions avoir
notamment dans les territoires ruraux
des ensembles territoriaux kiev qui
affirme davantage leur vocation à la
solidarité à la proximité enfin nous
voulons au point d'orgue terminer cette
réforme par une suppression des conseils
départementaux vous voyez là une
contradiction il n'y en a aucune la
contradiction aller chez vous d'ailleurs
je vais vous en voyez monsieur le
sénateur lefebvre à la fin de cette
séance un très bel exemplaire du figaro
magazine à la une du quel se trouvait
monsieur copé qui proposait au mois de
janvier 2014 la suppression de tous les
départements contre laquelle vous
semblez être aujourd'hui donc nous ce
que nous proposons de faire c'est une
réforme territoriale qui permettent dans
la clarté d'avoir davantage d'efficacité
enfin dernier point monsieur le sénateur
je termine par là ce que nous voulons
aussi c'est faire en sorte que cela se
fasse dans le compromis et le dialogue
parce qu'il n'est pas nécessaire lorsque
l'avenir du pays est en question de
créer nécessairement et sur tous les
sujets des polémiques c'est la raison
pour laquelle le président de la
république consult qui l'écoutent et
qu'au terme de tout cela les meilleures
décisions sont prises qui permettront de
faire la meilleure merci
mes chers collègues je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 16h15 pour
l'examen du projet de loi relatif aux
activités privées de protection des
navires la séance est suspendue
voilà donc pour cette séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement on
se retrouve tout de suite en direct du
sénat pour refaire ensemble la séance un
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre